Tensions are rising between the U.S. and Russia
over the Ukraine crisis.
So what happens if Russia decides it's not
in it's best interest to bring American ISS
astronauts home?
Welcome to DNews everyone, I'm Trace and this
is your Weekly Space Update.
First, I want to say, the conflict between
Russia and Ukraine is something NASA is monitoring
and our contacts there say that the landing
on March 10 and the launch on March 25 are
both on schedule.
Since the NASA space shuttle program is over,
the US pays Russia to take American astronauts
into space.
As of August last year the price was $70 million
per seat -- which is a lot.
What if Russia decided to just say "screw
this."?
How will our space nerds get our astronauts
back to Earth?
On the International Space Station, there
are always two Soyuz spacecraft ready to be
used as lifeboats -- but since this is hypothetical,
let's say they can't use those.
How would some of the more creative, scientific,
minds of our time envision getting an astronaut
from space back to Earth in a.... how shall
I...
Non-Traditional sense?
Lucky for us, during the early days of the
space program, engineers and scientists worked
on this exact problem.
Back in the late-1960s, scientists at General
Electric came up with the MOOSE -- Man Out
Of Space Easiest or Manned Orbital Operations
Safety Equipment.
As reported in a 1966 issue of Popular Mechanics,
the astronaut bails out of the spacecraft
and into the MOOSE where foam fills up what
looks like a life-raft and after the heat
of reentry, the parachute opens and a beacon
is activated.
It was tested by Mercury astronauts, but never
used or purchased, because... well, look at
it: It's a foamy raft thing in space.
There were other systems too, like the Paracone
or the Cocoon, both designed to be transported
up deflated and then inflated in case of emergency.
The Douglas Paracone was a ballistic cone,
basically a pilotable heat shield with a rocket
engine for re-entry alignment.
It didn't have a parachute, and would just
crush part of it on landing... the '60s were
crazy!
The Goodyear Airmat was an inflatable cocoon
ball for two space station-based astronauts.
The ball would be the heat shield, but they
never quite figured it out.
Rockwell proposed a giant balloon, not unlike
the space jump from a couple years ago.The
SAVER would have a small heat shield behind
the astronaut and a giant balloon in front.
Once in the atmosphere the balloon would inflate
and bam, the slow descent could start.
There were SO MANY designs, escape pods and
manned vehicles -- some were ruled out because
of weight limits, others because of cost to
develop the technology.
In the end, none of these designs were implemented,
or needed.
Ejection seats at space shuttle speeds would
tear humans apart -- so astronauts simply
accepted the danger as part of the risk of
space travel.
According to my sources at NASA, at the moment,
we've got no contingency plan to bring our
astronauts home, because we don't really need
one.
The space agencies of Russia and the United
States have always worked together outside
of their political differences.
Let's hope it all works out, because in the
end, space exploration benefits all of mankind.
Nerds don't care.
They got science to do!
Are ANY of these enticing to you?
Or do you have a better idea?
Subscribe, and tell us about it below and
we'll see you next week for more Space Updates.